[Music]
[Music]
who wants to see me do something
frivolous
and kind of lazy not you
too bad that's what i'm doing today
anyways i i'm
buried in a number of long-term projects
so forgive me for doing something that's
a little bit quick
to throw together and uh hopefully we'll
have some fun regardless so
i haven't messed around with one of
these tier makers before
i've seen other uh hooters do it looks
like fun
and the nice thing about this is because
the clusters tears together
this is not truly a re-ranking of
the doctors i will do that eventually
probably when jodi whittaker wraps up
her run
but for right now it's just going to
cluster them together no specifics so
let's get to it these are in a random
order
okay um who do i want to start with that
you know what you know it's going to
give me a good baseline to start with
let's just start with hartnell now the
thing with hartnell is i do
i like him i appreciate him i especially
like him in the latter end of his
run but he doesn't do much for
me uh as far as his incarnation of the
doctor like he's good and i appreciate
he led a lot of groundwork but he's not
who i'm going to go for comfort so i'm
going to drop him right there
um like i said there's a random order
back and forth back and forth back and
forth ooh let's go
with pertweed we're going to jump per
tweet
up a notch from hartnell it's kind of
funny to me because
i don't really love pertwee's era the
show kind of
delved into a lot of stuff that i'm like
it's a little too james bondy uh most of
it's earthbound
uh but you know what god
man's charming i'm just like like even
in this tiny little squish just look at
that smile
i'm okay i'm all right all right uh back
forward back forward
and
[Laughter]
peter davis i'm sorry i don't like peter
davidson
ah it's not even that he's actively bad
i just
don't get it whatever he's doing
i i have yet to clue into i've done the
show i've done big finish i just like i
don't
i don't know man all right back forth
back back and forth back and forth hey
who we got oh colin baker oh well of
course he's gonna go way
the heck up here
this is the power of big finish because
his big finish work is phenomenal and
they
write him so much better he gets to show
the sides of the doctor that tempers the
more
abrasive elements of the guy while not
eliminating them completely so it still
feels like the same character from his
time on the show but like just done
way better all right back forth back
forward back forward and
who would land on oh
boom s tier right to the top
right to the flipping top oh he
is so good and he got better
he me whatever you think about the show
itself i think he
in the role got better every single year
he
did it oh he was so good
oh come back daddy
what uh okay back and forth back back
and forth back forth
[Music]
oh tom baker you know where he belongs
that's an s to your doctor let's let's
not mince words
there's a reason why prior to
uh doctor who coming back he was the
doctor as far as most people were
concerned it's not just because he was
in the role the longest though i even
that helped a little bit
but the man just owned this role he was
made to play you could tell all right
back forth back and forth back more back
forward back and forth
where did i end up oh okay well i'm
underneath
ecclestone all right so where
are we gonna put you ooh this is tough
actually um
you know what you go up there my friend
and that i i feel you desert you
comfortably deserve to be there
and with him coming back for big finish
maybe maybe he can
live maybe
not quite yet though he's good though
plus i got to meet him so i'm biased
so let's see
[Music]
again not always a huge fan of the
stories that he was
in his error really did fall into the
base under siege format and that got
repetitive but
he's so good and he's just
he's so sly and clever and but cowardly
and runs away and he's nobody can ever
get a handle on
him he just they they always
underestimate him you see why we see the
way he behaves
oh he's so good all right this back and
forth this is getting too small it's not
really gonna work now
um ah heck
i'm gonna do it anyway uh back and forth
back forth back forth
uh far end well okay well that puts us
at
tenants
yeah yeah and
here comes the hate look
look he's good
i think he is good in the part i
like him however
he is too human for my
taste in terms of what i like about the
doctor
what he brings out in the character is
absolutely valid
i get why people love him he's charming
as hell
but they aren't the qualities that i get
attracted to most in the doctor and i
i've realized that over time
you know what i did that a little low
though okay you know what he
now he belongs there like i stand by
everything i just said but like that
that was a little harsh okay who else we
got
um
oh joe martin
this one's actually tough cause
she hasn't done much yet and i really
really hope she gets the chance to do
more
seriously if she never does really get a
proper series of her own it's going to
be such a waste
but like i'd be writing mostly of
presents and not a lot else
so the question is how high am i willing
to put someone based off
little screen time and a lot of presents
the thing is that presence was really
good
it's yeah yeah she owns
for those bits she's in oh okay back and
forth back and forth back
hey oh the valyard
this is an interesting one i find it
interesting that he's included since he
is
technically supposed to be an
incarnation of the doctor the one that
it seems pretty clear at this point is
probably never going to happen i know
some people still want the valley art
story to happen and it could and he's a
fascinating idea that is not done
particularly well you get the heck down
there
which like he belongs down there also by
design because he's like
the bad doctor so you know i don't think
you
even get to complain at me for that okay
back forth back and forth
like ah smith
i really did enjoy the heck out of him
in his time
i think if i'm being completely honest
part of it was narcissism because we're
the same age
so you know seeing him really felt like
oh it's like the doctor's me and
that's not a feeling that has lingered
as time has moved on
but i still i still feel that i still
enjoy his time and he he brought
he brought the weird back after tennant
felt a bit more like
classic hero so that i needed that
and he gave it to me all right
jodie whittaker okay
this one is a bit tough as well
and that like this is the reason that i
haven't
and i'm not going to do my full proper
numbered ranking until she's done
her time because i feel like that's me
being fair
since i it took me a while to sort of
get a sense of her
properly but like it did also take a
while
i'm gonna put her there she brings a
good presence but like i feel like that
there's
i'm still having a little bit of trouble
hooking into her
not quite as much as um as old qriket
ball over here but uh a little bit
a little bit so okay three left three
left three left
oh what to do
with paul mcgann
who was in that rubbish
rubbish garbage
tv movie but who cares he's freaking
epic yes look
paul mcgann is a doctor whose
greatness relies almost entirely
on big finish but boy did they do him
right and then the show remembered him
for a night of the doctor
and he slipped back into the role
gloriously for
seven amazing minutes
some of the best seven minutes the show
has given us in the modern era
i will hear nothing different
so who's this giving me left okay uh
well we save you and let's deal with
grumpy pants the legendary
john hurt who i really wish i'd gotten a
proper chance to shine on the roll and
he just
didn't like here's the thing he's not
even
bad but i feel like he is
never properly utilized i feel like his
reveal
is fantastic i feel like some of his
moments
uh in dave the doctor are okay but it
really should have been his
story and it wasn't so i didn't feel
like i got a proper sense of him
there and then when i started listening
to the big finish material which there's
more that i have to listen to
and maybe my opinion will change them
but i started listening to it i'm like
you're a
boring doctor
it's really unfortunate because john
hurt is so good
and he looks great it's a good look but
yeah i just i think
ah i'm being a little cruel there i
think he probably belongs about there
and the
i don't quite i can't attach to it
i'm not sure anybody belongs here you
belong there you stain your timeout
and finally sylvester mccoy
the chess master the game player
he is one where you have to stick with
him get to his later stuff
he gets better some of his stories get
better
but boy he's great again he just he
brings in the things i like the toying
with people so that they underestimate
him i
love his banter and how he how quick he
can be and he's
he can seem silly but then turn on a
dime
he's really fun i enjoy him quite a bit
and
there my friends is the tier
three at the top four pretty high
and then definitely passing like couple
notes were doing good like
uh see me after class and get the hell
out of here
so there you go did you have fun with
that i have no idea
i have no uh enjoyable
rubbish it's not really proper ranking
was this a cheat and also like keep in
mind i'm not going to adhere to this
when i actually do my proper ranking
when i do an actual numbered ranking i'm
not going to reference this video
i'm not so i might completely change my
mind between now and then so if you
think you now already know what i'm
going to do when it get when it comes
time for me to actually redo the ranking
put jody whitaker in there properly
you're wrong cause i am frivolous as
hell and i change my mind and things do
not stay in place cause
squirrel brain but thank you for
watching
i got a patreon uh if you feel like
supporting me
and keeping this whole thing up and
running and in fact what placement bills
this is my living if you like these
earrings
you'll find a link down in the
description now these particular ones
are
actually a custom item so you won't see
these specific items there but there are
pride colored earring items wonderful
stuff
in the etsy store take a look at it
paper cranes and pride
link below not a sponsor but
i was sent these so kind of a fan and um
like share subscribe comment how much
did i take you off with this whatever
your thoughts are down in the comments
let's talk about it
and uh you know plenty of stuff for you
to do but
no pressure take a relaxed attitude
around here clearly
this was a this was a relaxed
mess of a video so just come on back
that's that's the wrong sign off i
started doing the break room sign off
i think that i think that's instinct if
i'm sitting anywhere other than like the
the normal chair
i can't tell you what to do i can't even
get myself to do the things i'm supposed
to do
you're the council i'm just running the
meeting so i'm starting to wonder if i
even have the ability to do that
properly but until next time this
council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]